une première scientifique allaient
française et vient alimenter l'espoir de
trouver un jour un remède à la myopathie
une équipe de chercheurs a réussi à
faire fabriquer par les muscles d'une
souris la substance qui fait défaut aux
myopathes
le grand défi est la grande inconnue
c'est maintenant de transposer sur
l'homme cette première médicale
explications de jean daniel flaysakier
et michel jeanne latos des souris et des
hommes des souris myopathe et des hommes
qui cherchent comment guérir la maladie
humaine en guérissant d'abord l'animal
des hommes qui avance grâce en partie à
l'argent du téléthon et qui ont pour
défi de restaurer l'aspect normal du
muscle malades
l'aspect normal du muscle c'est cela à
vue au microscope des milliers de fibres
musculaires et chacune de ces fibres
contient une substance indispensable à
son fonctionnement
la dystrophine dans le cas de la
myopathie il n'y a plus de dystrophine
les fibres mort peu à peu le muscle
disparaît alors les chercheurs français
ont eu une idée
ils ont pris un virus qu'ils ont rendus
inoffensifs ils ont introduit dans ce
virus le gène de la dystrophine gènes
qui normalement fait fabriquer cette
substance par les cellules musculaires
et ont injecté le tout par voie
intramusculaire dans la cuisse des
petites souris malades ils ont eu la
joie de constater au bout de quelques
mois que près de la moitié des fibres
musculaires avait retrouvé un aspect
normal retrouvé un aspect normal c'est à
dire que ces fibres refabriquer de la
dystrophine il leur faut maintenant
trouver un modèle animal qu'ils soient
encore plus proche de la maladie humaine
la souris malgré le déficit n'est pas
très malade
c'est dû au fait que à mesure qu'elle
détruit ses muscles elle n'est
reconstruit
il existe une race de chien naturelles
qui sont des chiens myopathe qui sont
très très malade et il faudrait essayer
effectivement de les corriger c'est à
dire de les guérir par thérapie génique
mais le vrai défi sera de pouvoir
atteindre les muscles profonds comme les
muscles respiratoires ou le muscle
cardiaque et pour cela il faudrait
trouver le moyen de distribuer le virus
dans tout l'organisme
ce n'est vraiment pas simple mais c'est
seulement à ce prix que l'on pourra
commencer à parler de traitement pour la
myopathie humaine